what's this association between religion
and belief in ufos so for example you
just said an atheist may believe in ufos
and there's a religious like quality
because they believe in a transcendent
or they believe in transcendence okay so
i just see that as it's broadly similar
but i don't see it as being wholly
similar so there must be more analogies
than simply that so why don't you
outline that for the audience and myself
yeah of course okay so when you look at
um
when you look at
religion and you look at belief in ufos
okay so what you see first of all let's
get rid of this idea that religion has
to be exactly like christianity okay and
instead let's look at religion as a set
of beliefs and practices directed toward
that which looks to be of transforming
and transformative power okay because
that's you know that includes then
buddhism and you know some hinduism and
things like that so other religions
other than
jewish christian islam okay so then you
look at people who actually report
seeing or being
um in touch with inhabitants of ufos and
a significant um percentage of them have
a transformative experience after
they've seen one okay they're like wow
that really changed everything for me i
just now know i mean i've talked to so
many now thousands and thousands of
people who have had experiences of
either seeing a ufo or believing somehow
that they're in contact with ufos now
i'm not saying this is
true or false because in my field we
don't actually weigh in a very few of us
weigh in on what you know trying to say
this is a this exists or this doesn't
exist you can't prove it right
right now we just can't prove that so um
you know it's the same with religion you
can't prove
god it exists or doesn't exist um so we
just don't do that we just look at
social effects but we also identify
patterns so
when people so this is what i saw when i
started my work in um looking at people
who've seen ufos or believe that they're
in touch with the inhabitants of ufos
like extraterrestrials it i mean we
already have religions based on ufos
okay so we have nation of islam based on
ufo sighting uh realism based on a ufo
sighting okay so a lot of times people
will have transcendent experiences
either when they see a ufo or after
they've seen the ufo so the transcendent
experience that changes their lives
that's like a religious conversion
because that's you know if you look at
the history of people who have been
converted to religions you'll see that
that's the type of experience that
they're having and then a lot of times
these people have intense
uh long-term
behavior changes
okay where their value system changes
like maybe they were really about making
money you know um
and you know and all of a sudden boom
they have this experience of a ufo and
um
that you know these people are called
experiencers by the way people who are
um
people who've seen or
believe they're in conversation with
inhabitants of ufos they're called
experiencers and they've been around for
a long time
um but that you know right now that
because of media
and entertainment media
people are more inclined to look at
these events like when they see
something like an aerial phenomena you
know they're they're more inclined now
to say if they can't identify it as a
drone or an airplane or something like
that they'll say oh it must be a ufo you
know which is an unidentified flying
object absolutely but then that there's
a whole
group of assumptions that they bring to
that
um that interpretation so we're looking
at interpretive structures that have
changed
and that's why the ufo is now like a
rising what i would call not a religion
although we specifically have ufo
religions i would call it the rise of a
religiosity
what's the definition of religiosity
yeah so religion looks very distinct and
it kind of mimics or looks very similar
to say a traditional religion like
christianity in that you have a person
who has seen a ufo
and then
brings that information to other people
and those people become converted to
that religion let's say a nation of
islam or something like that and then
that's a very discreet
set of beliefs and practices all right
you're either a nation of islam person
or you're not okay
um but a religiosity
is more like what we see with this
spiritual but not religious community
it's a set of beliefs and practices that
people have that they don't have to
ascribe to they don't say
i absolutely believe in
this person's
idea of what the ufo message is it can
be it can um
it's basically
it's not discrete
it's a uh this dissemination of the
beliefs and practices
is decentralized there's no centralized
belief structure or institution
and people get their information through
each other on social media or through
media like star wars or something like
that right or through um documentaries
that are supposed to actually be
um
non-fiction right even new york times
you know where you see the tic tacs and
things like that
so and that's what i call religiosity so
a lot of people are having their lives
completely
or their let's put it this way that way
they're having their basic truths and
assumptions about reality shifted
because of belief in extraterrestrials
and that's that's what i see
and you also mentioned the phrase that
there's a transformative experience
where they radically alter their beliefs
or their
outlook on life afterward i believe you
said that was an element it's not a
surprising criteria but it's a necessary
one
i don't know if it's a necessary one but
it's it's a necessary well okay there
are different you know um there are
different varieties of belief in ets and
ufos so some people believe that they
were here in the past and maybe seeded
civilization actually dawkins has a
video out there if you youtube it you
know doc and zt where he basically
suggests something like that
or that someday in the future maybe you
know we'll be in contact with them or
something like that or that they're out
there but we'll just never be in contact
with them because the universe is just
you know huge
um
or they're in contact with us now okay
so these are different ways that people
believe in
ufos and ets